it's amazingly overwhelming
katy perry just revealed the sweet gift
taylor swift gave her newborn daughter
daisy and let's just say it's handmade
adorable perfection i don't understand
how you can not
girl about that on sunday katie shared
these snaps of a hand embroidered
pink satin blanket on instagram
alongside the caption quote
miss daisy dove adores her hand
embroidered blankie from miss taylor
swift
hope it's one she drags around for years
till it becomes an
unrecognizable shred that she keeps in
her pocket as a teenager
awesome naturally t-swift also included
a handwritten note and from what we can
see
it was dated may 3rd and she notes that
she had a similar blanket when she was a
kid
cute right i love it of course katie and
taylor have had a complicated
relationship over the years
the smile singer was rumored to be the
subject of taylor's 2014 hit
bad blood after an alleged dispute over
some backup dancers
but in 2018 katie sent taylor a literal
olive branch to help bury the hatchet
so i just got to my dressing room and
found this actual olive branch
this means so much to me then in 2019
katie appeared in taylor's you need to
calm down music video
confirming the two had officially made
amends
[Music]
but back to baby daisy katie and her
fiance
orlando bloom welcomed their little
bundle of joy into the world in august
and announced the news with this pic
writing alongside it quote
we are floating with love and wonder
from the safe and healthy arrival of our
daughter
i mean i don't know who's going to come
first her or the record we'll see what
kind of headlines she wants she wants a
she wants to be the opener or the closer
i have a feeling she does not follow
yeah in addition to giving birth
katie also released her new album smile
which she celebrated from her hospital
bed
tweeting quote delivering a baby and a
record in the same week
don't [ __ ] with mama let's go it caught
up with katie right before she dropped
her album
and gave birth and she revealed the kind
of mama she wants to be
i'm just excited to be able to um
you know raise her
in a different way that i was raised and
to
let her think for herself and have
choice
and you know discover and just
you know just lean into the magic of
life and and and probably
you know dress what like whatever she
wants to dress like for halloween
that's going to be really really
important i was never allowed to go
trick-or-treating
or note or dressing up that's probably
why i make up for it so much
i was in church girl you know all about
[Music]
it
you